زياده ملحوظه في انتاج القمح في اثيوبيا
خطوه تسعى فيها اثيوبيا لتخفيف ازمه
واردات القمح جراء الازمه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه عبر تعزيز الانتاج المحلي وتقليل
الاعتماد على الاستيراد خطوه غير تركيبه
المحاصيل الزراعيه في اثيوبيا من خلال
انتاج مليونين طن من القمح بميزانيه تقارب
المئتين مليون دولار لضمان امنه الغذائي
وبحثا عن الاكتفاء الذاتي
من زراعيا جيدا واستطعنا انهول السوق
المحلي بمنتجاتنا المحليه الوفيره ويمكن
القول ان هذا العام كان مختلفا عن سابقه
بمجنينه من محصول
وما تعطل الامدادات القادمه من الخارج
وتعدد السياسات الاقتصاديه ترى الحكومه ان
كميه الامطار الكبيره التي هطلت على
اثيوبيا هذا العام استطاعت ان تنعش زراعه
بشكل ملحوظ مما سيساهم في سد الفجوه بين
الاستهلاك والانتاج المحلي وتامين المخزون
الاستراتيجي اللازم لتحقيق حلم قديم
وتحديه الجفاف الذي ضرب المنطقه
الغذائيه اللازمه في بلادنا رغم عدم توفر
العمله الصعبه الكافيه ومن خلال جهودنا
المحليه يستطعنا ان نوفيجا كبيرا لسد
الفجر مستغلينه طول الامطار الكثيفه خلال
الفتره الماضيه
الاثيوبيه حمايه المنتج المحلي
تقليل دخول المحاصيل المستورده وزياده
انتاج المحاصيل المحليه لتشكيل حصانه
داخليه لمواجهه ازمه الغذاء العالميه من
خلال انتاج 10 ملايين قنطار حيث ان
اثيوبيا تستورد 17 مليون قنطارا سنويا مما
ادى الى تقليص الفارق في الطلب الخارجي
للقمح وساعد في تعزيز الميزان التجاري
والتشجيع على الاكتفاء الذاتي ومن ثم
الاتجاه نحو امكانيه التصدير بعد توفير
اكثر من 60% من الاستهلاك السنوي للبلاد
والذي يقدر بثلاثه فاصله تسعه مليون طن من
القمح مع استمرار الازمه الاوكرانيه
الروسيه والاضطرابات في امدادات القمح
العالميه تسعى اثيوبيا في تغيير اليتها
الزراعيه للتخلص من التبعيه للخارج وضمان
امنها الغذائي في ظل ظروف انك اقتصاديه
صعبه الاجنبي
سعيد مزين للعربيه من اقليم وروميا
الاثيوبي
[موسيقى]